be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so for those of you guys who were
following our videos on early start our
first video on J michael Straczynski
stork hadn't forgot about you guys it's
just been super super busy but we are
picking this up and in this video look
he becomes a chick loki becomes a woman
now in the last video we basically ended
with thor essentially recreating Asgard
in Broxton Oklahoma in this part of the
video we actually move forward to a
video that we actually did a rundown on
like we did have run down on Iron Man vs
Thor and that was really really fun that
was a really fun one to do but in order
to keep it in continuity with where I
just keep it in line with how we're
doing these videos we're gonna kind of
run over this again not super hardcore
but we're gonna run over this again
because this takes place after the
events of Civil War now remember during
the whole events of Civil War like we
were looking at that we were kind of
hoping the good guys would win they
didn't the bad guys well I guess what
passes for the bad guys one superhuman
Registration rent one out right now
there were a few things that came out of
civil war that even after Civil War we
didn't cover like we didn't cover the
Mighty Avengers which came after Civil
War that was basically the Avengers team
that served as kind of an antithesis to
The Secret Avengers right but the way
that played out is you basically had
Carol Danvers leading an Avengers team
they kind of operated as a long arm of
superhuman Registration right like if
you were if you weren't registered and
you were running around doing things
like Carol Danvers Avengers team would
catch up to you eventually Mighty
Avengers was rebranded at rechristen and
essentially became luke cage's Mighty
Avengers which included Adam Beshear the
blue Marvel which is really really good
it was a really good run but this takes
place almost immediately after right so
I Amman is now the director of shield
superhuman registration is in effect and
superheroes cannot operate within the
United States unless they register
themselves with shield in the federal
government the problem with this is that
this is Thor right so Thor just does
what he wants to and that's just the way
it is and is hilarious because I you
know when he gets to New Orleans of
course this is post Hurricane Katrina so
New Orleans is in a lot of ways
devastated getting in here remember Thor
is on the hunt for as Guardians but Thor
doesn't know explicitly what the
Asgardians look like right like all he
knows by virtue of what it was that
Donald Blake told him is that the
Asgardians aren't truly dead right like
their spiritual essences have basically
lived on and recreated in like created
human forms right like there's beings
that are out there where their speed
their spirits have gone into those
individuals and is up to Thor to find
them and so what he is up doing is
tracking down this guy who's out in out
in New Orleans you know and it's like
hey look like I know who you truly
even though you don't know and this
guy's kind of like well whatever man he
doesn't know who Thor is and that's
gonna be the common theme when it comes
to Thor rescuing these various ass
Guardians is they're not gonna know who
he is right they don't even know who
they are they're just kind of being
there there s their spiritual essence
it's kind of hidden and locked away
inside these various individuals the
problem with this is that where Thor
tries to talk reason into the sky
suddenly he's met by the arrival of Iron
Man and let me tell you something Thor
is pissed like Thor was already in in
like a really pissy mood
Iron Man makes it worse because what he
does is show up here this is one of the
things I love the most about the right
now when we did that episode right like
like I a man showed up here and like
he's he's tough right like he's the big
guy right like he's the director of
shield he's like that big dude on the
block I imagine like dude you have to
work within the system you have to
register and Thor just calls down the
Thunder and immediately like gets to
work like he starts going to work on
Iron Man and the reason why is it's
suppose you guys you never smelled a
rundown video and who never saw my
videos on Civil War during that event
what you ended up learning is that at
some point in the past I am an Reed
Richards these guys really more Iron Man
than anybody else had taken a piece of
boars hair so that if Thor ended up
perishing they could copy and they could
clone him they could make a new version
of him and they did that right the
character's name was Ragnarok which is
kind of stupid but they ended up
basically making like a robot version of
thoughts which run up when awry and
actually killed a superhero named
Goliath who is previously one of the
individuals who use Pym particles to
become a superhero and so as a result of
that you've basically got like Thor
sitting here saying okay so like let me
see if I understand this man so
basically I died or at least I was
believed to have died you know and in
order to to honor my memory you make a
robot out of me which in turn kills one
of our superheroes and then you show up
here on running up on me telling me that
I've got to follow your rules he's like
nah man like you're a human dude I am a
god man so like like I don't follow your
rules you follow mine and it's just it's
it's amazing because he immediately goes
to work on Tony Stark it's not even a
contest right like it's not even like
Tony starts putting up a good fight you
stand in a great chance no no no Tony
Stark is getting decimated like this
what are the coolest things right like
this is what are this is why I love J
michael Straczynski is riding he was so
good at this because it would be like
hey guys I'm gonna show you a fight and
I'm gonna show you a fight that's one
quite readily and in no uncertain terms
and it's gonna be awesome and that's
literally what happens here right like
Iron Man chooses repulsor beams Thor
hits it away I think there's there's
nothing that Iron Man can really do here
the response here of for is here is how
things are going to work
it's not even saying like let's come to
an agreement it's no no no no like I'm
going to tell you how it's going to work
and then you're going to accept it and
you're gonna go forward with it or
you're going to die and it's basically
like I rebuilt a scarred in Broxton
Oklahoma and there it will stay I am on
a mission to find my ass guardians of
what I do they will travel to Broxton
Oklahoma and they will reside in asgard
that's how it's going to be but you're a
fair your your your your whole thing
with your your laws of men and all that
kind of stuff doesn't apply to us
because at any given point we could just
say the heck with it and raise this
world to the ground so either you can do
what we tell you to do or you can perish
it could be easier it could be hard man
and so as a result of that iron man just
kind of like yeah dude good talk and he
basically leaves right he basically
leaves and he ends up traveling back to
his base of operations you're back to
dr. shield everything looking at how
readily his armor was destroyed by thor
and when the questions asked well what
do we do like are we gonna do anything
about Broxton or the response of Iron
Man is no we're not we're going to leave
it there and the reason why is because
they're playing a dangerous game right
like what we end up learning is this guy
that Thor was trying to get his hands on
that he's been talking to you once he
reasons what this guy was he says hey
look like it you don't want to leave
these people behind but you have a
higher duty here and you have to recall
what that higher Duty is and so the
results of that is this guy basically
says okay and then he basically allows
Thor to bring that essence out and we
end up finding that this guy is Heimdall
right now this is the reason why Thor
went for him is because Heimdall is all
seen he can see everything out there and
so in response to that what this means
is that with Heimdall on the side of
Thor and Iron Man basically saying hey
look I don't know exactly that's if
that's what's going on but I do know the
things are kind of popping off here
they'd be picking a fight with gods the
Avengers would be foolish and they
decided to go to war with Asgard you
would need some big heavy hitters
fighting on the side of the Avengers in
order to be able to win but the chances
of those guys actually working for them
or slim because Iron Man's pissed
everybody off so like no one's gonna
really sigh with it if I man shows up to
like the super you to to all the
superheroes who have gone underground
wit his hat in his hand is saying hey
guys so like I kind of screwed up and I
need your all's help to basically
survive against Asghar they're gonna be
like sorry about your luck you know and
they're gonna send a package and that's
basically gonna be it and so as a result
of that what you end up getting is Thor
jumping from one location to the next
traveling to various locations he ends
up traveling to Africa basically dealing
with these freedom fighters and the
freedom fighters are being led by what's
basically the Warriors 3 it's a cool
thing to see Thor moving from one
location to the next
and basically waking up these various as
Guardians
then gathering together and having them
returning to their previous form now the
cool thing is he doesn't just he doesn't
just like bail out right so like in the
instance of these African freedom
fighters it's not as though he shows up
here and he's like excuse me everybody
everybody stop what you're doing I gotta
wake up my guardian friends and he wakes
them up and it's like okay guys
everybody back to it gotta go and then
he basically leaves he stays in in
fights right these days it helps and
that's one of the important things to
bear in mind when it comes to Thornton
is at the moment the the priority in
what Thor is doing is waking up the
Asgardians are bringing them back right
but it's not like he's gonna leave a
country of innocent people to die and
just be like that's just kind of the way
it goes man it's business as usual and
call it a day the cool thing about this
is that once the Warriors three are
restored knowing notices Thor is going
with the people he trusts the most right
he trusts Heimdall more than anybody
else because Heimdall really has no
reason to lie
Heimdall's loyalty is absolute loyalty
is to the protection of Asgard it's the
role he serves right and not only that
of course he's got the all-seeing eye so
basically you can't tell for where to go
and who to look for it but at the same
time bringing in the Warriors three are
his most trusted battle his most trusted
companions when it comes to to engaging
in conflict and so what is it happening
here is Heimdall basically points Thor
in the direction of a place where
various individuals are being kept being
kept in prison this place is kind of him
his place is locked off nobody's really
supposed to know but he basically says a
huge number of our group of us s
guardians are being held here in this
location by a foe that I can't tell you
about your big enough to go and you're
going to have to face his foe on your
own and do the best you can when he gets
in there when you basically start
winning ends with discovery what this
flow is it's the destroyer armor the
Destroyers got a long history when it
comes to Asgard right the destroyer
armor was originally created by the sky
fathers but mostly Odin in order to
basically defeat the Celestials or at
least to challenge the celestial spot
the destroyer armor is an insanely
powerful piece of technology right like
in an insanely powerful beam and so Thor
facing off against the destroyer really
takes all he has and it's cool to see
that because when that happens and when
the destroyer armor is is ultimately
defeated by four the destroyer armor
cracks open and out falls Balder the
brave and this is cool because if you go
and you look at Norwegian mythos like
the actual Asgard uh I guess really the
real mythos of Asgard in here in the
real world the fates had be cried that
if Balder the brave were to die that it
was signal the starting of Ragnarok and
that's one of the reasons why Balder the
brave was bathed bathed in waters to
where if he was basically immortal the
only thing that would that that was
missing was a single section of
in Marvel Comics bought of the brave is
similar in that regard but if he dies it
doesn't mean Brian Rock is going to
happen the cycle of Ragnarok the way the
prophecies were laid out is that Loki
was the one who was gonna kick off
Ragnarok and so it really it really ties
somewhat into the real world mythos
insofar as bald as a character who
basically Nellie was always like if he
dies something bad will happen that was
really kind of the gist of it right it
was the idea that if Balder died the
cycle of Ragnarok would start it wasn't
until you started getting into the years
leading up to Thor disassembled in the
Ragnarok story that it was like baller
doesn't really have anything to do with
it at all he can die and it'll suck but
it's not gonna start Ragnarok it was
basically Loki will start Ragnarok he's
the source of it all and so as a result
of that Balder basically speaks to Thor
and says like the idea here was that I
had always existed in such a way to
where it was my job to protect Asgard
right like if I fell Asgard would fall
as well and the problem with this is
that when I felt I had failed in my
mission I failed to protect Asgard and
so as a result of that I didn't really
know what to do like it was an internal
conflict in myself between accepting the
fact that Asgard had fallen there was
nothing I could have done about it and
the fact that I failed and so as a
result of that what it what it basically
did is it led to him basically being
thrown inside the destroyer armor and
then gathering all of his people
together and it really led to him
imprisoning them but regardless of the
circumstance with Balder being freed of
course Boulder's basically sent back to
Asgard and so what is up happening as
Thor gets in here and he's grabbing the
last of the people who were there and he
ends up coming up coming up on a woman
who he believes to be safe and as he
starts talking as he says you don't turn
around my love you know it's good to see
you again my beautiful woman my
beautiful dear the love of my life he
turns around and it's Loki Loki becomes
a chick Loki's a girl but Loki being a
woman is amazing because what he
basically did was steal the body of
stuff he stole the body that was meant
for him now here's the funny thing is
low-key kind of parades around and
really presents himself to Thor in such
a way where he's basically harmless
because what he says is like my entire
existence leading up to the events of
Ragnarok was to cause Ragnarok but like
everything I did was for the purpose of
causing Ragnarok of getting to a point
where Ragnarok will basically be
initiated by me but that was the sole
purpose that I have that's all that I
was really supposed to do and now that
I've done that there's no reason for me
to be a bad guy anymore
I'm basically starting over I'm starting
from scratch like I'm doing things all
over again
I'm busy
be a good guy now now for it stems a bit
of an olive branch but the olive branch
is on a pretty short leash right I mean
Thor's not like whoa okay brother I
trust you man like it's awesome to see
you again bud
it's cool to see here because will we
end up learning this this is this is
this is one reason why I love the
character of Loki so much what we end up
learning is that none of this is what it
appears
because what Loki does is start
community he starts communicating with
somebody who we can't see and Loki
basically starts saying that Thor is a
bit of a goof Thor trusts people
implicitly or trust his Asgardians
implicitly which is not the worst thing
in the world but there are as Guardians
out there who want to see him fall and
so as a result of that what Thor will do
as Thor will basically lie and wait and
Thor will start releasing different
people based on those he can trust the
most of those who can trust the least
but what's what's going on here is Loki
saying we can basically have our chance
you and I working together as those
individuals are released as Thor begins
to release those individuals who he
trusts and whom will operate under the
guise of I'm here to fulfill my purpose
and I don't really have any ill-will
against you Thor they will lie and wait
and what they'll be waiting for is
somebody to help them make a move
somebody who can help them achieve their
goal without fear of being totally
obliterated by Thor whatever that goal
happens to be most likely to fall of
Thor and so with this individual who
Loki's speaking to you if you know he's
basically saying if we work together we
can work alongside those individuals who
want to see you our fault and we can
bring ruin to Thor we can bring him down
and then we can we can basically plunder
Asgard like we could seize control of
that entire place and the person you end
up finding out Loki is talking to you is
none other than probably the greatest
villain in all of Marvel Comics Victor
Von Doom Allah Doctor Doom with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain make sure you guys to
the sub button to become part of the
robb for if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Applause]
[Music]